[Applause]
happy glorious tuesday my precious
friends and fans
last sunday america's media suffered a
tragic loss
no cnn didn't lose its viewer
it happened on fox news sunday
if i can't go home and explain it
to the people of west virginia i can't
vote for it
and i cannot vote to continue with this
piece of legislation i just can't i've
tried everything humanly possible i
can't get there
you're done this is this is a no
this is a no
wow that was pretty good huh
who knew it took chris wallace to leave
before the sunday show breaks actual
news
i kid the chris we're very close
he went off to something that's called
cnn plus
good luck chris but one tip avoid bring
your children to work day
for their sake
cause you know a lot of perverts over
there
so there's deep sadness for the press
who invested so much in a different
outcome you know it's like leaving a
bunch of christmas presents in your car
only to find out that while you're in
the mall getting a pretzel somebody
broke into your car and stole them all
some breaking news
senator manchin has just said that he is
a firm no on this legislation
mansion is a mercurial person to be
dealing with from people i've talked to
within the white house we know this to
be true uh and he you know may want to
be a king maker in some ways when it
comes to this legislation this is joe
manchin wanting to extend the joe
manchin show period
at least he has a show who is that guy
anyway did you hear that audible gasp
from the first panel of mourners sounded
like someone was standing on wolf
blitzer's oxygen hose
or maybe
someone accidentally clicked on tubin's
feed
that would cause me to gasp
turns out they were devastated they
didn't get the trillion dollar spending
bill they neither bothered to debate or
much less read
yeah they were mad that their side lost
and that was it it was once again
politics as sport and they bet 20 grand
on the heavily favored team and they
lost
and like the crybabies they are they
lost and wanted to take their ball and
go home although in stelter's case it
was probably a meatball
because he likes to eat
just in case he didn't get it
hearty eater susan
and poor jennifer rubin one of the truly
broken casualties steamrolled by trump
she wrote that democracy is now hanging
by a thread
which is exactly how your family will
find you in the basement if you ever
read her on a regular basis
that crack bot's been wrong more times
than boris johnson's barber
she makes no sense
mansion operated just as our political
system should it's a republic he stood
up to both the hard left progressives
and the media's hysterical pressure and
told them to shove it up their
collective puckered asses
it's just a biological description
he put his constituents first you know
those rubes that the media despise
loathsome gas bag bette midler described
west virginians as quote poor illiterate
and strung out
all things you'd have to be to sit
through one of her movies
i'd rather be waterboarded with mountain
dew than watch beaches
yeah i don't care what's she gonna do to
me
later she was forced to apologize for
saying what she believed and what the
media entertainment and academia believe
too that they're smarter than all of you
but of course they aren't they're stupid
i mean who mourns for the death of a
bill that they didn't even read and the
bill sucked from the start it's based on
a strategy meant to make it impossible
to analyze fact is everything the
government produces is gigantic on
purpose
including their mistakes you know it's
like an insurance company that puts you
on hold the goal is to wear you down so
you give up
remember this great line we have to pass
the bill so that you can
find out what is in it
away from the fog of the controversy
yeah you have to pass it to see what's
in it
which is exactly what my drug mule said
to me
[Laughter]
r.i.p drug mule
pay first then see what you're getting i
don't know that logic doesn't work in
the real world does it
[Music]
and then he said it's probably malignant
thank you i'll get this
oh excuse me miss uh yeah there's a
problem this doesn't list what we
ordered and it says i owe you eighteen
thousand dollars how can how can pad
thai be eighteen thousand dollars well
you also ordered a diet coke
so why don't you pay now and then we'll
discuss this afterwards
well can you tell me why it costs this
much now this is a lot of money
can you just pay now you racist please
[Music]
you had to get the shrimp
yeah
but there is a bigger picture here when
biden ran for office he had to clear a
very low bar a return to normalcy is
what he called it he pushed that bit of
business and then he returned to the
basement and curled up in a doggy basket
next to an old bowflex machine
everybody has one normalcy meant his
resting heart rate of zero
but yeah after four years of wearing the
leather jacket of donald trump
it was time for america to put on that
fuzzy warm cardigan that was old joe
except it turned out that cardigan was
made of a type of wool that everybody's
allergic to
and even moths couldn't stomach the
taste
with soaring inflation and escalating
crime waves still denied by the
democrats and a pandemic panic worsened
by a befuddled president
a new poll finds that 70 percent of
voters call this a bad year with over
half saying it was awful for them
personally and that doesn't even include
the cuomo brothers or alec baldwin
of course that poll is from fox news so
you know uh this is it's gauging how the
voters feel and not the politicians or
the media and it shows yet another
record low for biden so how's that for
normalcy
others in the media don't look at it
this way they don't ask you about it
when they see that you're suffering they
frame it as how does it affect the party
we support that's why they ignored the
crime wave because it was bad news for
them even though it was bad news for
everyone including you politico worries
that dems will lose at least one if not
both houses of congress in the midterms
while average americans worry they'll
lose their real houses as the economy
tanks it says everything that the media
mourns a bill that would have taken
inflation to new heights because it
meant their party lost everything is how
it will affect their party their bottom
line meanwhile america didn't expect
much
or even ask for much just a little bit
of order a little comfort a smidgen of
optimism instead we got everything
royally effed up we were promised a
comfy bathrobe and we got a onesie made
of steel wool
sounds kind of good at this point
period
let's welcome tonight's guests
santa has her on both lists
nice and extremely nice fox business
correspondent susan lee
he has the face of your nephew and the
politics of your dad host of the guy
benson's show and fox news contributor
guys
he's the hockey fan who put the fbi on
ice former white house national security
council aide caspatel
and finally his jokes get a worse
reception than kevin spacey at a high
school dance
writer and comedian joe devito
guy good to see you as always merry
christmas you look very comfortable
thank you i'm taking a page out of your
book sartorially if that's a word yes
with the little uh sweater tie combo yes
yes yes so i figured you know it's been
a crazy week i don't feel like dressing
up you know everybody
you know i'm in charge of this show guys
do you think the democrats are secretly
against this bill and just hid behind
joe manchin and he probably got like
some anonymous support for this oh yeah
definitely i'd say one or two and when
he's out there sort of taking all the
fire he's the lightning rod on things
like the filibuster there's probably six
or seven saying thank you joe it works
for you back home it works for us just
to keep our mouth shut as long as this
thing doesn't move forward which it
hasn't
i find it interesting with that whole
monologue in the position that we're in
as a country
the white house put out a memo right to
tell all of us that in fact we are
better off today than we were a year ago
and i read it and i stand corrected i
feel great yes uh i i all the things
that i've been feeling and witnessing
and experiencing in my life it's all
nonsense there's some talking points
that jen sake threw together right and
we're great the problem for biden is
that people don't believe it yeah and
you reference the fox news poll if you
don't like a fox news poll
because there are very dumb people who
think it's like sean hannity pulling his
household right write a fox news poll
like no it's actually a bipartisan thing
it's a very good pollster there's a new
npr pbs poll good enough i would hope a
lot of letters tess biden at 41
right 29 among independents the american
people aren't buying this in hispanics
he's getting killed brushed yeah crushed
by hispanics not literally just in the
poll
i'm totally against that susan how dare
you laugh at something so violent
by the way
you know how did i get invited into this
reverse outnumbered episode i'm like one
lucky girl here yeah instead of one
lucky guy
nicely done yeah
i don't know how i got the short straw
but okay
is that a jab at me or joe
what's what's hype got to do with it you
know
what
that way but okay
that's how it's been taken what would
have happened if this trillion dollar
spending uh bill passed what would
happen to the economy when we already
see
inflation over almost seven percent
right
it would go to it would go to at least
and this is just my uh uh conservative
prediction a hundred percent
it would go to a hundred percent yeah
well okay so joe manchin said no to two
trillion but he's a counter offering 1.8
trillion
yes big difference
you still get 600 billion dollars for
climate and he's making some i think
he's making some reasonable counter
offers saying you have to be a taxpayer
in in order to get a child tax credit
right per se that makes sense that makes
sense and by the way he's also offering
a payroll tax he's trying to find some
way to actually pay for this package i
mean we're already at 29 trillion
dollars in debt yes that's like one and
a half times the u.s economy yes the
government is spending three trillion
more than it takes in every year that's
not sustainable doesn't even maybe it is
and we don't know maybe we just where do
you print the money from where do you
get the money from no we just did it
from here where we were wrong the whole
time and you could just keep printing
money what if we were completely wrong
and he's like no you just keep printing
it zimbabwe has tried this actually yes
and it does not work well you know what
there are other you know what it was in
ba it was a zimbabwe dollar
that's the difference yes
you're on to something don't question my
uh stupidity cash
uh if trump ran again your old boss
would he even have to campaign at this
point no no
i mean look he went down to texas last
weekend yeah and the motor i i drove in
about 40 or 50 of his motorcades while
he was president yes and they were the
craziest things i've ever seen yes he's
now no longer president and the texas
motorcade was longer than his
presidential motorcades wow i'm not
kidding the secret service literally
were like what are we supposed to do
he's not present anymore we don't have
enough guys that's amazing just because
of the crowds or yeah just because the
crowds and the people that showed up and
lined the streets they have to figure
out a way to secure him so no he doesn't
have to actually campaign and he's
probably just going to save a ton of
money yeah there you go can it get any
worse for joe
uh i mean sure why not
when you look at that photo i i would
have to say yes
it's like you know i had this and use
this analogy before i said he's like you
know when you get you have a new car joe
the other joe and it gets in an accident
or it gets stolen you just want the
insurance company to total it you don't
want to like say you know you we can
repair this and we'll pay the bill no
because it's never the same it has a
different smell
you know that's kind of what this
presidency is for the democrats they
just want to total the car
yeah it's the the old car smell you
don't hear a whole lot about that
the old car smell
that's usually cigarettes and aftershave
and shame yeah and there's a little bit
of like a a liniment
a bit of limit that was stained into the
into the ceiling that was covered with a
blanket because it tore there's a tear
in it you thought just putting the
blanket over it and tucking it in would
work yeah well because the skin sticks
to it yes exactly exactly
uh yeah those were the days what uh
should i ask you
okay fair enough
usually i don't ask the questions for
what the question would be but that's
one approach well you're a strung out
person uh did you take offense to bette
midler's tweet she was talking about you
well uh i did not take it personally yes
uh i think it's interesting that she has
her apology and people say oh do you
really think she's sorry she just did
hocus pocus too she has no conscience
that is true
so i think one of the things we've seen
over the past couple years is that if
there ever was a veil over the way these
people view the rest of the united
states it's been ripped back right she
clearly sees people of west virginia as
a bunch of meth addict hillbillies and
then to say anything afterwards like oh
well i didn't really mean that for the
fine people of west virginia well it's a
little bit late for that yes exactly so
yeah and it's just interesting to see
the elite reaction because i'm sure when
they heard mansion they thought oh we
love our mansions and they were like oh
no not that kind of man
yeah i'm glad that somebody in the
democrat party had had a little bit of
common sense and they say one man
shouldn't have well it's not the one man
there's also the 50 people before him
right common sense too so we really
dodged and unless the joe biden found a
huge stack of cash somewhere in his
closet or his golf band we're very lucky
i'm not in his closet yes not yet anyway
you know uh you don't want to piss off
meth heads because they don't sleep
where's cat by the way
[Laughter]
oh
nicely done